well brian a big unveiling today as
mccarran airport showed off its
innovation checkpoint it's actually been
two
years in the making leading up to
thursday's opening
madison kimbrough was at the reopening
today and has the details
welcome to inside the terminal where we
are giving you an exclusive look at the
reopening of mccarran's innovation
checkpoint i would tell you the crown
jewel of
test sites for tsa and for the future of
aviation security
is right behind me getting through
security at mccarran airport will now be
easier and cleaner with the latest
upgrades in aviation security
technologies
this is absolutely the most superb and
one-of-a-kind
the only one in the country that has
this kind of technology this
one-of-a-kind checkpoint
offers additional security screenings
new digital signs for travelers to
easily see what they can
and can't bring through security and a
digital reading of security wait
times for travelers to see firsthand one
of the biggest features is the
credential authentication technology
also known as cat the system takes away
the need for a boarding pass
and all you need is your id other
features include an automated bin return
using an ultraviolet light system to
clean the bins
travelers say convenience is key but
they are pleased with the sanitation
measures added
i think that's cool i wasn't really
thinking about the bins but
yeah it totally makes sense if they're
self-cleaning that sounds awesome it
sounds like the technology is catching
up which should be great
and this new checkpoint opens thursday
morning reporting from inside of
mccarran international airport madison
kimbrough
8 news now by the way plexiglas barriers
have also been installed along with a
new body scanner that is meant to reduce
the number of pet downs for each
passenger